we're leaving the customs union which
would mean that if we stayed in it we
wouldn't have control over our
international trade policy and the Prime
Minister wouldn't have set up the
Department for international trade she
wouldn't have been out in China looking
at the broad future my export
opportunities that we want to tap into
if we weren't going to do that and I
think it's important to understand why
that she's been very clear on this all
along because having a free trade from
Latin America to Asia is good for jobs
it'll also increase the productivity of
our domestic economy which is good for
raising real wages and also in terms of
free trades got a long track record of
reducing prices so in terms of easing
some of the cost of living pressures on
lower middle income families is very
important that's one of the great
advantages opportunities of brexit so
it's important that we grasp it but
again you have Philip Hammond and Liam
Fox saying things which frankly are
entirely at odds with each other now
these are not backbench MPs they're not
shouting protesters at carriage gate
there are senior members of the cabinet
who are seeing entirely different things
about our future relationship with the
European Union so again I'll ask which
is it is Liam Fox correct that we cannot
have that continued close alignment with
the European Union or is Philip Cowan
right when he says that we can I think
you're rather caricature in both of
those but look it's absolutely right and
Liam Fox is not saying anything
inconsistent with what the Prime
Minister has said to say we want to
grasp the global free trade
opportunities for the reasons I gave and
equally it's of course important and
Philip Hammond is is right to be saying
look let's make sure that we manage very
sensitively and carefully and
responsibly our trading relationship
with the EU the ear is our biggest
trading partner but the opportunities
the future will probably in fact
according to the eve the European
Commission's own analysis will come from
those emerging economies from Latin
America to Asia so it's about getting
the right balance and it's great that
Michelle Barney will be in London we can
thrash out some some more of those
details and of course it's not just
about what we say it's about what's in
their interest as well so we're going to
look for that win-win deal and I think
it's important for everyone to get
behind the Prime Minister to make sure
we get that best deal that we possibly
can are you honestly saying mr. Rob that
the government is speaking with one
voice on this matter that there is not a
fundamental difference of opinion around
the cabinet table when it comes to our
future relations
with the European Union is that what
you're saying no I think there are
inherent tensions in dealing with breaks
it because but different people take
different views it's not just in the
Conservative Party it's not just in the
Labour Party it's across the country and
actually we need a bit of a team effort
here that's what I'm saying loud and
clear and we should be rallying behind
this Prime Minister in this government
and David Davis is doing a tremendous
job in the negotiations and making sure
that we carry people with us I was a bit
too you you know that we've discussed it
before but I also understand the
importance of mitigating the risks of
brexit as well as grasping the
opportunities and it will require a team
effort and that's what we need to see
okay but just on that basis then I'll
ask my second question once again do you
think that after we leave the European
Union there is any possibility that we
could be in a form of customs union not
the customs union at but an arrangement
which differs from it what looks like
quite similar no I don't think we'll be
in any form at least as conceived in
international trade practice of customs
union because if we were we would have
our hands tied in negotiating free trade
deals with other parts of the world
whether it's Brazil whether it's China
or India and Prime Minister's been very
clear we want to be able to grasp those
opportunities but at the same time we
want frictionless trade with the EU and
so there will be important to go see
Asians on the technical detail of making
sure that actually goods and services
can flow freely across the border so
that's the distinction in a week when
the spectator of all publications that
puts on its front page at leader goal
can you honestly say that Theresa May is
doing an effective job of leaving your
party can you look directly into that
camera you know and tell the electorate
I think the reason is doing a good job
yes because I think first of all brexit
is inherently difficult look at the
shambles of the Labour Party's
positioned on it but I recognise that as
the government of course this incumbent
upon us actually to deliver this but
what I'm saying is it's an inherently
sensitive issue it's a crossroads moment
for Britain any army I'd expected there
to be tension as long the way both in
terms to the politics here at home but
also in terms of our negotiation of the
EU so what matters most is a team effort
a bit of discipline there I say a bit of
emotional intelligence along the way as
well not react to every negative story
that the media want to ham up
and actually focus on the prize which is
a win-win deal with the EU but also
grasping the opportunities of brexit and
that's what I'm 100% focused on and
that's why I think and-and-and the
overwhelming majority of MPs are behind
the prime minister in that regard
have you read the Sunday papers this
morning I mean have you seen any of the
stories that are around this morning
about which it clearly sourced by The
Sunday Times 10 shipment from you know
senior cabinet sources or colleagues of
those senior cabinet sources telling the
prime minister look if you don't do what
we want we're going to fall we're going
to have a coup when you see make those
stories yes and I've got huge respect
for the Sunday Times and for Tim Shipman
in particular but lots of these stories
are anonymous sources there is clearly
tensions in Parliament and in the wider
country about this but what I would say
to you is that I think the public know
this the aim out for this is that the
media magnify all the negatives and
actually the overwhelming majority of
MPs and ministers that I talk to in the
ministry for housing when I was at the
Ministry of Justice welcome to David
Littleton who was a remain and but and
right across Parliament we focused on
keeping the economy driving and firing
all cylinders yes getting the best deal
we can for brexit we know it's going to
be a team effort and also dealing with
some of those important other social
issues like housing which I'm taking
forward with Sajid Javid and the
minister of housing team and we've had
some important work we've been doing
this week on that so the vast majority
are focused on that but I'm not saying
there are no tensions we will discuss
you briefed it in just a moment but some
have suggested that perhaps one of
treasom is at biggest recent mistakes
and admittedly something of a crowded
field that was not giving Jacob Riis
Mogga a ministerial post putting the
reins on him instead this week he
accused the Treasury of fiddling the
numbers making things up
I mean is he correct is he correct about
fiddling figures yes no I don't think so
I don't think there's any fiddling and
figures I mean why has he been allowed
to get away with it for so again why is
he being allowed to get away with it
well look Jacobs a very thoughtful
contributor to the brexit debate he's a
backbencher he's got the freedom of the
back benches but I just say this about
forecasts because you asked about it and
and it's sort of presented a very
politicized where I read Kirsten Forbes
or Kristen Forbes
to Bank of England forecasting she was
on their committee at the Bank of
England step down very renowned American
economist and she's made the point that
some of these forecasts are inherently
uncertain and actually the forecasting
model is flawed and so I think it is
fair to say that look some of these
forecasts have proven wrong in the past
and treating them like a science is is
bound to end up being proved wrong but
my experience of the civil service in
the current Ministry of Housing
commuters and local government is that
there's a great can-do attitude huge
level of expertise and so I don't think
it's right to start criticizing
individual civil servants or
bad-mouthing the civil service as a
whole actually they're doing a great job
and it's you know it's a challenge for
them to so you you don't identify them
in the ever-lengthening list of enemies
within them and we have the judiciary
the media the the CBI I mean the civil
service isn't part of that list you've
never heard me talk about anyone's the
enemy within look I can tell you I've
been doing the housing job now for less
than a month and what I've been struck
at the Ministry of Housing Communities
and Local Government is the great can-do
spirit a lot of creative thinking and
you know real excitement a real buzz
about this challenge we've got of
building the homes Britain needs and
making it more affordable for the nurses
the teachers and the young families I
want to get on the housing ladder so
actually I think we've got a great team
and that look all I can tell you is my
experience day-in day-out and I go into
the office okay give us some of the
creative radical thinking that's going
to solve the crowed the crisis in
housing that well there's no silver
bullet there's no magic one but we've
done two things this week which I think
are important one you've seen the papers
probably today the announcement that
we're going to allow local authorities
the flexibility the freedom to build up
it when they need to meet their housing
targets and that's important because
whether it's providing apartments
whether it's terraced housing we want to
make sure that they've got the freedom
to provide the homes that they need in
their local community and at the same
time earlier in the week we had our
homes infrastructure funding and it was
a 866 million pounds which will unlock
200,000 new homes but the real point is
this when we're encouraging local
authorities to build more homes and
people rightly ask but where will the
the roads be to deal with the congestion
or will we be able to get our kids into
the local school what about the pressure
on NHS services we'll be providing the
funding not just to build those homes we
need but to make sure we have the
infrastructure to build up and
strengthen our communities as well so
those are just two examples of a range
of reforms we're coming forward with to
make sure Britain as the homes we need
and to make them more affordable I said
for the low earning lower middling
income families for the next generation
that believe and and sharing the
conserve division of home ownership but
but but can't currently get on the
housing ladder we want to make sure one
thing you would not claim them so sorry
to trouble one thing you would not
countenance is building on the green
belt you're a bit of an MD aren't you me
personally yes well actually if you want
to look at my record and I've argued for
for example in my constituency the
expansion of a local infant school on
the Greenbelt when there were no other
options why because I think it's really
important that the we're talking about
housing but I haven't been an in be in
the way you've described there of course
existing safeguards which are really
important because we cherish our
Greenbelt and though you know they're
not absolute but they they need they do
need to be respected and but overall
whether it's planning reform which is
important and that's why the building up
announcement is so important on density
releasing public sector land making sure
builders once they've got their planning
permission actually delivered the homes
that they've undertaken - and also this
targeted investment we keep going on we
can build on our existing record two
hundred and seventeen thousand new homes
built delivered in last year and get to
that level of three hundred thousand new
homes being delivered each year and
that's important because not only will
it provide the homes we need but start
to see the affordability come down for
the nurse for the teacher for the young
families that want to get on the housing
ladder and that's the plan and we're
we're restless and really straining to
get cracking on it